hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round 5 of this
year's video World Cup after eliminating
Hikaru Nakamura pregnant now faces the
very strong Hungarian Grandmaster
Finance berkish who also defeated many
strong players to reach this point he
defeated uh he he played one more game
one more match than pregnant is pregnant
that was seated directly into round two
uh verkish was not in the top 50 so he
had to play an extra round he defeated
Daria purini he defeated both his
girlfriend he defeated Nikita of endo
Ruslan ponomario now he has to beat
breakdownanda and he's 38 years old at
the moment 21 years ago at the age of 17
he became a world champion under 18
years old so here Prague is facing a
former world champion uh let's check it
out this is the second game of their
match first game in the draw 10K can he
hold Prague with the black pieces let's
see how it goes uh Prague opens with
Ponte E4 and we have Pawn to E6 Finance
Ops for the French defense with D4 D5
and progress for Ponte E5 the advanced
variation of the French we have Pawn to
C5 striking against white strong Center
and C3 with Knight to C3 Knight to F6
and now Queen to B6 putting more
pressure on the D4 pawn and of course
hindering the development of the dark
Square Bishop so here we have Pawn to A3
repairing Pawn to B4 and now Bishop to
D7 the main move here is just a pawn to
C4 this is the uh the most played and
you know you actively fight against
White Plain Pawn to B4 but here Penance
prepared a less played line Bishop to
d7n process all right you didn't stop
before so I I am going to play at Pawn
to B4 uh a sign of a great player does
not hesitate to play B4 as soon as
possible C Captain D for C captures and
Rook the C8 putting the Rook on the only
open file on the board Bishop to beat
you and now Knight G2 E7 we have Knight
to C3 and now notice that the bishop and
B2 is undefended so that Finance uses
this to pretty much solve all of his
developing issues and that is by playing
Knight to A5 now of course you cannot
capture because Queen captures some B2
and Prague has to decide what to play
here this is still known territory and
one move that has been played here is
Knights to A4 with the idea of Shifting
the Knight to C5 so while it can be
played let me just show you what happens
for example Queen C6 you will attack the
Knight here and uh once the Knight comes
to C5 you will put your own Knight to C4
so both Knights nicely placed here you
will of course save the bishop with
Bishop back to C1 chase away the Knight
Knight will trade for Bishop um about
okay the light Square Bishop isn't that
impressive all of the pawns are on light
of course it's the dark squirrel Bishop
you are interested in Queen characters
and now you can play Bishop to D3 and
okay the game continues so this is
something an idea that has been used
before but process I don't like this he
just goes for Bishop to D3 and it is now
as of move 11 that we have a completely
new game
it's okay ferencer gets his Knight to C4
as intended and Prague has to waste a
move with Bishop to C1 of course you are
not giving up your your Bishop for
Knight here uh and pawn to A5 very
nicely done we have castles and now a
captures on B4 now before we capturing
this you don't want to uh uh blunder
upon uh Rook to B1 nicely aligning the
uh Rook with the black queen queen back
to A7 and only now a captures on B4 we
have Pawn to B5 cementing the Knight on
C4 and pragos on to H4 the black king is
still in the center of the board so you
might do some Knights the G5 Queen H5
action the bishop is nicely placed on D3
maybe some future sacrifices with Knight
captures on D5 uh you never know so here
we have Queen back to B6 uh adding a
Defender to the to the B5 Pawn because
as long as the Knight and Bishop are
attacking the B5 Pawn you can't really
move the C4 Knight anywhere so for a
moment let the queen defend the pawn
Rook to E1 and this is a beautiful move
by Prague he says how do you how does
white improve his position here after
Queen to B6 you know the bishop is very
nice the knights is very nice okay this
Knight is very nice you could play
something like Bishop to D2 okay the
bishop obviously can be improved from
the C1 square but progress for the very
active Rook d one idea the plan being
rookie two Rook A2 and of course uh well
Rooks somewhere along the a file you'll
see where one to H6 and now rookie two
with Bishop to C6
and okay Square for the bishop but uh
for the moment the bishop is more more
of a pawn there you still have to figure
out how to make use of the light square
of the ship we have Rook to A2 and now
Bishop to B7 and here probably goes for
a very very interesting Rook to A5 idea
saying that this is a a great Square for
my Rook I can even double up on the a
file and if you want to capture well
then this would happen if Knight
captures an A5 Pawn captures an A5 Queen
captures then comes Knight captures on
B5 with the thread of Knight to D6 check
so we're gonna play Knight to C6 in
order uh for the bishop to guard the V6
square but after Knight the D6 check
Bishop captures and pawn captures uh
this is a Monster Pawn you still have
the bishop pair you're gonna defend it
easily with Bishop to F4 you can shift
to the bishop over to uh to this
diagonal and this will be very very hard
for black to play so this is prague's
idea behind this very early uh exchange
sacrifice so ference decides nope not
touching that he just goes Bishop to C6
adds another Defender uh to the B5 pawn
and now Queen to EQ we have bought the
G6 and The Rook B to A1 nicely doubling
up on the a file and now Knights the F5
this is a great Square for the for the
black knight uh Rook to A6 now attacking
the queen and queen to d8 and here
probably just plays Pawn to G4 and
invites ference to uh to capture the
opponent H4 as the Knight and queen are
both attacking it and believe it or not
here you have to you have to say nope
not touching that one I have to go back
with knights D7 and slow play this with
something like 97 Bishop to D7 and try
to basically you're waiting for a white
to find a a game plan here but here
Knight captures and H4 was played and
this gives uh Prague a completely
winning position it's not that easy to
see why unless you see it then it's very
easy so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Prague while I give you
a couple of seconds
foreign
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting this uh very
tough tactic and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
captures on H4 that's the way to do it
uh Queen captures an H4 and now the idea
you had to see in order to play Knight
captures on H4 Bishop captures on C4 but
now what does this do you might think
well let's see after B captures now
comes Rook captures on C6 so those are
the three captures we had to see Knight
captures on H4 Bishop captures on C4 and
Rook captures on C6 which creates the
Unstoppable past B Pawn which of course
would not be possible if the pawn was
not already on B4 so Rook captures on C6
and now Rook the A8 with check and now
the problem is there's no good Square
for the king let me just show you what
happens if King D7 it's it's basically
Checkmate uh Queen to F3 threatening
Queen to F6 check so we're gonna block
that with Bishop to G7 off-road Rook
trade but now Knight captures on D5 with
check e captures and Rook A7 check
nicely connecting with the F7 Pawn so
King to d8 but now you don't even touch
the df7 when you play Queen captures on
D5 with check King to E8 and now Queen
to D7 with the check you don't need to
take the rock king f8 and queen captures
on F7 will be Checkmate so Bishop uh
King t7 loses uh very very quickly so
King the D7 was played and now proc
still needs to work for his meal but
Queen to F3 the F7 Pawn is undefended
and pawn to F5 this is how ference uh
tries to defend his position and now
while you could go for something he
captures an F6 Alpha saw you could play
G captures on F5 uh pragos for the very
nice Pawn to B5 and while this is
incredibly strong it allows black to
trade off Queens uh however proc says
nope this is completely winning for me
there is no problem here Rook the C8 was
played and now Knight captures on D5 and
here uh of course uh felons needs to
trade Queens if he accepts the Knight
then it's just a beautiful Checkmate
Queen captures on D5 King to C7 Rook a 7
chicken it doesn't matter where you go
it's going to be Checkmate so instead
after Knight captures on D5 Queen
captures and G4 was played this comes
with check and now Queen captures F
captures and Knight to B6 nicely
connecting with the Rook here King to C7
Knight captures and now King to B7 you
have to chase away The Rook from the
defense of the Knight Rook to A6 and now
King captures on C8 uh Prague captures
an E6 King to B7 and now Rook captures
on G6 probably just continues um at a
happily connect collect pawns even
though Bishop to E3 is also very strong
you just will take away the B6 Square
from the black king Advance the pawn so
you don't have to worry about King to B6
and this will be a very much uh winning
for white but the road captures and G6
is also fine uh Pawn to C3 and now Rook
the C6 going after the past pawn bishop
to B4 defending the pass pawn and now
Bishop captures an H6 proc collects yet
another Pawn Rook the d8 going after the
D4 pawn and now okay you could just go
back like with Bishop T3 proc just goes
back with Rook to C4 Bishop to A5 and
now Pawn to E6 advancing the past Pawn
King to B6 and now Pawn to E7 with Rook
to E8 and now comes Bishop to G5 you
have to defend the pawn otherwise you
cannot win this game uh King captures on
B5 and now Rook the C5 with the check
King to B6 and Rook to D5 so now you
don't have to worry about King going up
the board as the bishop Hayes hanging so
Bishop back to B4 and now Rook to d8 now
uh Finance has to give up the The
Exchange and Prague will have to beat uh
his Bishop with a rook so Rook captures
an E7 Bishop captures Bishop captures
and now of course a rook to C8 going
after the past Pawn onto G3 there's
really not much more you can try here if
you play Bishop to B4 okay you're
defending the pawn uh but it's not
really I mean it it the pawn Will Never
Move the the king can never cross the uh
the C file the the past the Deep one
will just March forward you will ring
your king into the game and that's it
this Pawn is not really an issue so here
one last trick was attempted by felons
he played Ponte G3 it doesn't work
unless Prague really really messes up
but okay I mean you're still gonna try
it before resigning uh the idea of
course is that um
uh if you uh well what if you play F
characters on G3 then Bishop to F6 and
then Rook captures uh on C3 uh then
Bishop captures on D4 will just uh pick
up the rook and of course this will
allow him to draw the game but after
Bishop to F6 simply D5 was played and he
was in this position and move 50 that
felons beckish resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the pawn will be promoted to a queen
there are no more tricks you don't have
to worry if C2 will be met by Rook
characters if the king attacks The Rook
you don't really care just Rook the C4
then the King goes after drug but you
again again a square so there's there's
really nothing you you can try here even
if there was no Jeep on it still be
winning but with the g-pawn I mean you
can just play literally anything so uh
yeah after after this D5 move uh here
ference resigned or or maybe he didn't
let me just check one more time I just
want to really quickly check if this was
where he resigned uh
oh no sorry uh it was after Rook
captures and C3 really that uh what
sorry about this no this can't be uh the
the PGN on on the website is still wrong
no no this never happened after D5 I
hear a parents resigned yes there really
is nothing more to be done here I'm just
gonna really quickly check this as it's
you know sometimes it happens that the
pigeons get broken online
uh so
let me just quickly check a valid
resource
I like uh like leeches or something uh
let me check this all right
there we go
[Music]
ah sorry
seems that after G3 yeah of course F
characters was not played Rook captures
and C3 was played in this position yeah
and it was on move 49 at that my friends
backish resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here see I
almost uh tricked you guys into
believing that was the the ending
position where in fact it was this so
you know don't trust all the pigeons you
see online some of them are just uh you
know some of them are just faulty
obviously yeah big congratulations to
pregnant on eliminating ference from
defeated World Cup he continues uh his
uh Onslaught to win the World Cup into
the quarterfinals and these are some of
the pairs that we have from the
quarterfinals as you can see gookash
will face Magnus Carlson and Egypt I was
always waiting uh for his opponent it
will be uh well it will be either uh
yaniponashi or vidit depending on who
wins the their match tomorrow in the tie
breaks then we have caruana versus
Dominguez and uh we have an Indian
matchup uh pragnan that will face Arjun
Erica so those are the the pairs of the
quarterfinals what's going to be going
to be absolutely incredible so I hope
you hope you stay tuned I I most
certainly will uh so yeah that's the
game really hope you guys enjoyed it
nicely done by uh both of them uh they
reached all the way but the only one you
know as a Highlander would say there can
be only one so what do you want to do uh
I would like to thank Emily
Philip huxtenberg Serena Mass Cash up
and E1 check for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the Fida
World Cup until it finishes uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day